hey guys how's it going today we are
going to be unboxing something that I
got on eBay I don't know what it looks
like I don't know if it's going to work
and even if it doesn't work I don't even
know if I have a place that I can even
plug it into we are going to be unboxing
the original iPod now this isn't in mint
condition I don't know what condition it
is I ordered this a really long time ago
and I actually forgot that I wanted to
unbox it for you guys so today's the day
let's do this ooh so excited firewire
[Music]
this is crazy
firewire plug I leave any remember oh my
goodness it seemed a little case in
everything Oh bless you little song
whoever over this one thank you for
taking such good care of it like I want
to cry like I'm actually emotional right
now and I'm disgusted with myself but I
am I'm extremely emotional okay
oh my sweet baby you're what started it
all you are the most beautiful I can't
believe what I'm holding in my hands
it's a little scratch but all things
considered it looks pretty good my nails
notch it so that's nice it's actually a
pretty good condition the question that
I have is will it start up and how will
I put this in I'm gonna have a converter
here's the headphone jack
there's the firewire port and here's a
little hold so that if you would hit any
of the buttons it would skip we're going
to plug it in
it's starting up oh my god I'm freaking
out I'm freaking out right now I'm
freaking out like I'm freaking out oh it
is work they have music on here already
listen the click wheel I don't want to
like I don't want to cry cuz I don't
want another one registered being
cringe-worthy again but like I can't
believe that I need to get some
headphones I was already but the only
items that I could find you were these
and they're Samsung let's listen to a
song cause
[Music]
that's really not much more that I can
even say I'm just so excited this
actually works the original one that I
had it ended up getting just extremely
beat up and just filled my parents house
but I found this one and you remember
when I got a lot of eBay that it
actually looked in pretty decent
condition and it said it worked and it
does and I'm super super impressed
I can't even just just let's go just cut
to a little montage of how good it look
[Music]
arrows smugly can't believe it looks so
freakin good
so happy so I question to you guys is
what tech do you reminisce about
something from your childhood no matter
what age you are right now I feel like
technology it changes so quickly that
something even if you might have had
last year is completely out of date now
so things are moving at quite a rapid
pace and this iPod this came out let's
see I want to say 2001 2002 gasps 2000
more in October 23rd 2001 it was about
eight and a half months after iTunes was
released
what really glad this actually still
works I'm going to put this in a very
very special place glad you left me some
music just caught me through some really
tough times it got me through some great
times and it got me to where I am today
so this little guy I love you it's
thanks to January 2002 that's pretty
wild this little game are you kidding me
okay so it's hard to play while I'm
looking inside of a monitor that's over
here this is so awesome
to really get to re-experience this I
wish that I could rearrange this and do
the full unboxing back in the day but
back then I mean I don't think I was
unboxing things around 2001
unfortunately that happened until a
couple years later we'll see you guys
the next videos let me don't have
anything else that you would like to see
me unbox I have a few fun things planned
here for the next few weeks so I'm
looking forward to showing you those so
see you guys later bye
oh yeah this is gonna be great
don't speed ahead baby okay okay okay
stop oh yeah quite what I was going for
but I'm not really sure
[Music]